respond with his back to the basket  Mubarak it'll work on jobs hard to five  reform he turns on heart leaves him in  the dust still plenty time to go though  it's not to Kuzma LeBron's of purring  and a good deferral  for three Davis dives to the rim to the  wob LeBron called forth  and Davis Winton got it bottled up and  ripped by LeBron James  James took it himself and finishes at  the rim chambermaid played keep-away on  socks now branded into the lane lunch  into two pigs stole my butterfly to onto  the pond down the middle LeBron all the  way the Frog scores nine on the front  long June butter the six on the clock  long  he's feeling  with 23 and he's gone over 33,000 points  for his career  I'm doubling that no double-team he  kicks it out it's the right place whose  and you say why well that's the right  plate of it